We are listening to the questions and comments
from folks through discord, David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
Speaking of Ohio, let's go to Chris in Cincinnati.
Chris, you're on the air.
Why, thank you so much, David.
So I just want to start a little bit with
a point in which we can agree on, because
I do kind of like pressure you a little bit
on to your thoughts on the, like, AOC kind
of controversy.
So.
Would you say that if your goal is progressive
policy and a non corrupt government, that
policy probably wouldn't be a good speaker
of the House?
You're saying in in a vacuum?
I don't think about it that way.
I don't think Pelosi I'm not excited by Nancy
Pelosi because I just don't find her to be
nearly progressive enough.
So my preference would be for a more progressive
speaker of the House, you know, absent any
other political realities in a vacuum, I'd
rather someone more progressive than Nancy
Pelosi.
Right.
I think we can agree on that.
So I think Politics 101.
Right, you if you don't agree with a specific
vote, you don't agree with voting for Nancy
Pelosi for a progressive policy, then you,
of course, want to leverage your vote.
Right.
You'd want to, like, get something out of
voting for Pelosi, whether that be a more
progressive speaker of the House, which is
very unlikely, or maybe getting some political
concessions out of Speaker Pelosi cracked
up.
Those would certainly be things that one could
seek.
Yes, right.
So what we'll see is came out and said what
she would be trying to leverage for her vote.
The first thing she said was a 15 dollar minimum
wage, which is like incongruent with like
any sort of leverage, because Pelosi and Biden
already said they're fighting for that.
So it doesn't really make sense.
And at best, it's just kind of misleading
and gaslighting.
OK, hold on a sec, man.
We can can we talk about that when you when
you say what AOC would want in exchange for
her vote for Nancy would be a 15 dollar minimum
wage?
The language is a little bit confusing because
how would I see voting for Nancy Pelosi get
a 15 dollar minimum wage?
Do you mean a vote on a 15 dollar minimum
wage or what?
What specifically?
That's that's a great that's a great question.
So what she did, what she said in response
to how she's leveraging her vote for Nancy
Pelosi, it'd be if I vote for Nancy Pelosi,
I have Bakhtawar kind of conversation with
Nancy Pelosi and make an agreement with her
that I will support her for a minimum wage
if I support Nancy Pelosi.
Hold on a second.
No, I think you just said something totally.
I will support her for a 15 dollar minimum
wage.
If I think maybe you just misspoke.
Can you say that again?
AOC said what exactly?
OK, so you can read the tweet that she said.
But she's saying she's leveraging her vote
for Speaker Pelosi in order to get a 15 dollar
minimum wage.
That was directly her tweet.
She did it in response to Justin Jackson on
Twitter.
OK, I'm just saying I don't fully understand
what it means that she she wants to be getting
a 15 dollar minimum wage is something that
would have to pass the House Senate and be
signed into law by the president.
So I'm trying to understand I'm not saying
you're giving me wrong information.
I don't understand what it means that she's
leveraging her vote for a 15 dollar minimum
wage because I just don't see how Nancy Pelosi
can make that happen.
Is she talking about a vote on a 15 dollar
minimum wage?
That's a great question.
I think these kinds of the exact question
that you're bringing up is kind of proof that
what AOC is saying in response to leveraging
her vote is kind of incongruent with not only
the way this would work properly, but also
like.
Well, that may be that may be I guess it depends
on what AOC meant.
I'm just not totally since I haven't seen
the tweet, I it's possible that it's clear
what AOC meant in the tweet.
But you.
But I'm not hearing from you.
I just don't know.
Well maybe you should stick on that then.
But I think the point is there I just find
it interesting that there is this whole debacle
on Aoki's response to Justin Jackson in part
of this controversy.
And that was really part of it.
And that's part of what the what I'm trying
to say, what is the main point and what is
the main thing?
It was part of the disagreement about forcing
the vote, part of that disagreement saying
AOC wasn't left enough.
Right.
I mean, I'm not going to say the disagreements
are OK.
Listen, I don't know that I want to.
I want to I want to have this conversation.
I just I'm really struggling to know what
you're talking about when you say that was
part of the disagreement, what was part of
which disagreement between which parties?
There was a disagreement between people on
the left, like Jimm who is OK.
There was a disagreement between Justin Jackson
and Brianna Joy, great and secular talk with
Aoki's policy making decisions in how she's
leveraging her vote.
First we see.
OK, and this disagreement was on.
And it came in response to Justin Jackson
on Twitter, and that's what really sparked
the controversy, of course, the vote on top
of Jimmy Dore's crazy outward rants about
how Aoki's corrupt, which I don't support.
OK, OK, so AOC said in response to Justin
Jackson, Justin Jackson saying on Twitter
that if you don't leverage your vote for Medicare
for all, which is like hashtag Forcillo, then
you are showing who you truly are kind of
saying like it's a litmus test.
And AOC responded to Justin Jackson saying
we are leveraging our vote and we're doing
it for 15 dollar minimum wage.
OK, who is just who is Justin Jackson?
Sure he is.
And he is an NFL football player.
But on Twitter, he's a very active leftist
who frequently goes on a Katie Helper's show
and on the Joy Grades Bad Faith podcast.
OK, I don't know who.
So let me I'm going to try to bring this back.
Maybe maybe this is just not the right venue.
I don't know who Katie Halper is.
I know, Brianna.
Joy Gray was was Bernie's former former person.
We're like 10 layers deep and telephone.
Was there a specific question for me on policy?
Sure.
Yes.
OK, on policy, I, I would hope that you could
just expand on what you think would be the
best way to leverage your vote for Speaker
Pelosi.
Like maybe we could talk about that or you
could expand on if we're going to vote for
Nancy Pelosi, progressives.
I mean, you going to vote for someone we don't
clearly agree with?
You already said that.
What is the best way we should leverage our
vote for Speaker Pelosi?
OK, I have a segment coming up about this,
and I'm going to lay out in detail exactly
the things that I think would be more more
reasonable.
But if we're going to stay even in this paradigm,
if I were AOC and this doesn't mean this is
the right thing or the wrong thing, I would
be more interesting, more interested in pushing
for something that whole if I'm going to hold
my vote hostage, I don't want to do it for
a naughty, nice list on Medicare for all.
I would rather do it on standing firm on twelve
hundred or two thousand dollars for people
that need it just as one example, like I can
come up with all sorts of other examples.
But I think there's actually a bigger picture
question here about the types of things that
members of Congress can try to get from the
speaker that are beyond symbolic votes to
do a naughty and nice list, which includes
things related to committee ships.
And it's a long list.
And I'm going to have that clip very soon.
All right.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
I'm sorry because I was undeclared, but I
love your show.
Thank you.
And as a leader, my friend Andre Gray had
a great article on, like what this kind of
effect would have, and also David Sirota on
how to leverage your vote properly.
But thank you so much, David.
All right.
Very good.
Pleasure.
Pleasure, pleasure.
Hopefully we were able to make some sense
out of that eventually.
I mean, I think we got to something interesting
ultimately